qu'est ce que tu veux toi
c'est arrivé ici c'est un club privé
qu'est ce que ça veut dire en club c'est
pas nous c'est les bains douches c'est
un club privé il ya une soirée plus
value mais tu rentres tu as fait ce
qu'on m'a dit croire entre les doigts
dans le nez tu rentres pas tout seul
même tout serait parce que j'ai des
copains matériel même avec des copains
c'est un club privé comme on s'y
attendait c'est sympa on attend dé nous
mêmes avec de l'oseille on n'a pas
besoin de la carte bleue même la carte
bleue lambert a les cartes il a cité
acteurs c'est pas pareil menteuse marine
tu peux rentrer et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus